hallo ich meine lieben freunde und
herzlich willkommen zur ice hockey
challenge das ist sonne gegen challenge
zur damaligen bier competition auf
facebook wo man damals eine papier bei
facebook es dann dürfte man seine
freunde markieren das ist jetzt diesmal
muss ich einen kompletten eimer voll mit
1 über den kopf schütten und kann danach
auch drei leute nominieren bei facebook
machen das unglaublich viele promis und
stars ich hab gedacht ich habe das mal
so ein bisschen in youtube ich habe das
ganze gerade gemacht habe alles in
zeitlupe aufgenommen allerdings sind
diese kamera bei zeitlupe keinen ton auf
ihr seht schon da sind noch so ein paar
nasse stellen auf der bank und ich würde
einfach jetzt vorher schon mal sagen
viel spaß dabei ich habe gerade geduscht
und mir war richtig kalt danach ich
nominiere regenzeit roth pilz und kran
crafter ihr habt eigentlich 24 stunden
zeit aber bei youtube ist das ja ein
bisschen was anderes mit dem ablaufplan
deswegen würde ich sagen ja da hat uns
ein paar tage zeit zu 34 tage mag ich
auch an die beschreibung werde nominiert
ist und dann würde ich sagen jetzt viel
spaß bei dem video das euch gefällt
würde ich mich übernommen und